well I threw myself into the civil
rights movement and into the student
movements of my generation the anti-war
movement we could put about 10,000
people in the street in about two hours
time in those days we deployed in
Michigan like an army all over the state
shut down the university in 1968 with a
big after kent state shootings and
invasion cambodia but i was i was always
always trying to figure out a foundation
for my life I knew I wanted to be about
social change but what's the foundation
for that so I left the church or
basically they kicked me out but but I
never quite got shed of Jesus so when I
was a senior I began to read again the
Gospels to give it one last chance I was
reading Karl Marx and Ho Chi Minh che
guevara all the revolutionaries but then
I began to read Jesus Sermon on the
Mount that really turned everything
upside down you know blessed are the
poor and the poor in spirit blessed are
those who hunger for justice for they
shall be satisfied blessed are the meek
for they shall inherit the earth blessed
are the peacemakers whether they should
be called the children of God this was a
radical reversal of the logic of the
world and it proposed to change
everything starting with me and then I
kept reading in the book of Matthew at
Matthew 25 the 20 for Chet was my
conversion pass this is a famous one
where it says Jesus as I was hungry I
was thirsty I was naked I was sick I was
a stranger I was in prison and and you
never came to see me you weren't there
for me and they all say Lord when did we
see you hungry and thirsty and naked and
sick and in prison had we just known it
was you he would have done something
would have formed a social action
committee or something but but he says
as you've done it to the least of these
you've done to me and I was blown away
by that this was more revolutionary more
a radical that any of the
revolutionaries I was reading and I hear
is this the the in the text the Son of
God saying I'll judge you by how you
treat those who are often left out and
left behind this was this was amazing to
me and so I thought it was simply more
more radical more transforming anything
I ever heard or seen and so I signed up
to be a follower of this Jesus not to be
in the church I wasn't ready for that
but to follow Jesus I went seminary and
that's where I met a bunch of other
people that's when we started sojourners
a long time ago